the OverWatch league in its current form
is done the league itself hasn't
announced anything yet but overactive
media the parent company of the Toronto
defiant has said that blizzard has
agreed to forgive millions of dollars in
deferred franchising fees then a
follow-up report from Sports Business
Journal confirmed that all existing
OverWatch League teams would be offered
the same result it's the end of one of
esports's biggest ever experiments and
it's dismantling could change Esports
forever
foreign
folks before we get into the video I
wanted to let you know that we've got a
new show coming out this weekend and I
think you're gonna love it it's called
into the dark and we're making it in
partnership with crack and rum it's this
great dive into the stories behind
Gaming's biggest protagonist as they
took these incredible leaps into the
unknown and emerge Victorious It's
unlike anything we've ever done before
and I know because I'm actually doing a
lot of writing on this series you're
going to love it so you can check out
the first episode on June 10th if that's
too long to wait we've already got a
trailer up on the channel the link is in
the description below okay so let's just
quickly get up to speed all the way back
in January Esports journalist Jacob
Wolfe reported that OverWatch League
teams had hired sheridans a British Law
Firm to essentially negotiate on their
behalf with the league citing very high
operating costs and disappointing
Revenue then in May Activision Blizzard
King revealed that their professional
Esports leagues the OverWatch league and
the Call of Duty League were in higher
straights the reveal came as part of a
10q filing which is a quarterly filing
that publicly traded companies are
forced to make if you want to go more in
depth on those events we have videos on
both of them but that should be enough
to get you up to speed for what we're
about to talk about so it was pretty
obvious that something had to change and
even blizzard admitted that in that 10q
filing that I pointed out where they
essentially said it might not be
possible to resolve these issues well
now we know what the first step to
resolving this thing will be and that is
that blizzard has forgiven franchising
fees for overactive media aka the
Toronto defiant and presumably based on
reporting from Sports Business Journal
that will be offered to every OverWatch
League team see when these teams joined
the league they agreed to pay tens of
millions of dollars in order to do so
but they didn't have to pay all of that
up front a lot of it was deferred and so
those teams have these outstanding
balances now blizzard is saying ah don't
worry about it we know this because
overactive media reportedly one of the
organizations that had played a leading
role in the effort with that British Law
Firm a nasty agreement on Monday they
said that the elimination of the fees
plus a sponsorship deal with OverWatch
League of some kind represents a nearly
11 million dollar value in Canadian
dollars so overactive media announced
this but the other teams didn't and it's
important to note that overactive who
owns again the defiant are a publicly
traded company so this is something that
they would likely need to disclose at
the same time though the defiant were
actually one of the League's first
expansion teams so it's likely they paid
even more than those initial crop of
teams based on reporting at the time but
a subsequent report by Hunter cook and
Kevin Hitt in sports Business Journal
said that the same resolution would be
offered to all OverWatch League teams
and may even be extended to teams in the
Call of Duty League the sports Business
Journal article quoted sources that said
the teams in the Call of Duty League
might ask Activision Blizzard for this
the same deal and they also said that
quote Allison Walker Chief commercial
officer of oam tells SBJ that we are
open to having similar evolutionary
conversations with Activision Blizzard
on the Call of Duty League okay but what
does this actually mean for the future
of the league well the answer right now
is we honestly don't know the spga
report I just mentioned also says that
there are now Provisions in place to
allow for the entire thing to be changed
going forward in terms of formatting
business model Etc so you could expect
to see some changes eventually if not
sooner rather than later whatever form
these changes take the admission from
ABK that things do have to change means
that CEO Bobby kodex vision of a
Prestige Esports League competing with
the NFL and NBA is dead now but that
professional sports model only works
because leagues are able to give each of
their teams a slice of a pretty big pie
the broadcast deal that gets so old to
actually broadcast the NFL or the NBA or
whatever OverWatch league as I pointed
out before did try to use broadcast
deals as part of their business model
seemingly they signed deals with both
YouTube and twitch at various points but
clearly this was nowhere near enough and
as Blizzard's reputation suffered hit
after hit from controversies even
advertising seemed like a difficult road
to use for Revenue in a sense even if we
have something called the OverWatch
league in the future this change seems
like an absolute death knell for the
kind of franchising that became so
popular in 2017. it's an admission that
to have a league like the NFL or the NBA
you need to have some Revenue if not
right away then at some point and with
everything else that's happened codic
has just run out of time to make his
dream a reality maybe he was never
really that plausible built as it was on
guesses of future growth and bolstered
by celebrity hype but this is a firm
rebuke to the idea that the only thing
standing between Esports and Prime Time
success is a well-connected CEO who's as
loved by other business people as he is
disliked by his own customers listen
OverWatch league is not the only League
to come up against difficulties we're
following the LCS walkout situation I
definitely recommend checking out
Danny's excellent video on that for a
good overview but those changes that
earn the ire of The Players Association
were designed to lower costs for teams
in the league it seems obvious to me
that franchising and the elimination of
relegation in applicable Esports and
leagues was always going to lower the
level of competition in the short to mid
term but the argument that that
trade-off is worth it because of the
financial stability offered to the teams
and their business partners seems pretty
foolish in hindsight now the one thing I
can say about this resolution is that it
isn't the worst possible ending no this
isn't a Fly by Night style retreat in
the vein of Heroes of the Storm where
blizzard killed off its players Esports
dreams after a lengthy period of silence
and drop the announcement right before
Christmas
classic blizzard now this outcome seems
to suggest that blizzard and its teams
are very open to the possibility of
future cooperation whatever form that
actually takes I don't have these
contracts in front of me so I don't know
for sure what blizzard might have been
able to do and similarly I wasn't in the
room when Sheridan's was advocating on
behalf of the OverWatch League teams so
I don't know what the teams might have
threatened to do it's nearly certain
that blizzard had a harder line they
could have taken here but they chose not
to do that whether that was out of fear
of their teams openly rebelling or
perhaps out of a genuine desire to just
move this thing forward and find a
solution that works for everybody
it's what happened hopefully that means
that some of the impact of this thing on
the Esports industry itself can be
moderated and the Deferred fees are a
pretty good start when reached for
comment by SBJ blizzard said that they
look forward to sharing more details
with their players as they get closer to
Grand finals so it's likely that we'll
see some news about this new format and
how the league will change soon enough
now allow me to wax poetically for a
minute I know I know but I can't shake
this feeling like the summer of 2023
what we're going through right now is so
different from the summer of 2017 but I
remember that pretty clearly I remember
standing on our office balcony
frantically confirming details so we
could break the story of the Houston
Rockets involvement in the LCS afterward
I remember going to get some more fresh
air staring up at the Toronto skyline
and thinking [__] is this actually
happening it turns out it was all a bad
dream if not a complete nightmare now
all that's left is to interpret the
signs and figure out how we can move
forward
I don't know I I hope if you're in the
area of the smoke I mean there's many
areas of the spot right now stay inside
I've been chilling down here I got an
air filter that I run when I'm not
filming I don't want that smoke you know
not in the figurative sense or the
literal sense I don't want that smoke